good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 899 object class
euclid formerly safe see intimate
reports special containment procedures
SCP 899 is contained in a rough patch of
forest in Rocky Mountain National Park
the SCP a 99 phenomena has not been able
to travel more than five meters beyond a
standing living tree thus the area has
been isolated by creating a continuous
fire break around the affected region
three park service cabins are staffed by
foundation agents on the borders of the
site for the purposes of preventing
hikers and travelers from attempting to
enter SCP a 99 agents are authorized to
administer Class B and C amnestics to
any trespassers children who enter a CPA
99 cannot be recovered and containment
must be maintained by removing those who
have knowledge of the child's last
whereabouts or by planting false
evidence of death by natural causes
elsewhere in the region agents who come
into physical contact with SCP 8 1990
lers psychiatric evaluation as the SCP
899 phenomena has become increasingly
more violent all trees within 5 metres
of observation cabins have been removed
personnel entering a CPA 99 must do so
in pairs and carry sidearms with custom
iron ammunition
description SCP 899 is a psychic and
telekinetic phenomenon that most
commonly manifests as groups of hostile
phantom children travelers in the area
have reported being pursued and harassed
by small shadowy figures that curse and
throw rocks in an attempt to drive them
out of the immediate area
the figures tend to be featureless and
it is usually difficult to determine if
they possess any gender or even
individual voices and behaviors failure
to leave the area will result in an
increase of aggressive behavior
culminating in a direct physical attack
by the entities an adult who comes into
physical contact with one of the
entities will suffer the loss of all
detailed memories prior to the onset of
puberty general knowledge of family
members and living conditions will
remain but persons who have been
affected by this memory loss often
display a significant change in
personality the most common symptoms are
loss of impulsiveness and curiosity and
negative responses to attempts at humor
affected persons also tend to become
highly impatient with children
regardless of their prior behavior
pre-adolescent children who come into
contact with the entities will
physically disappear after which some or
all of the entities may take on parts of
the lost children's appearance no
attempt to communicate or find the
whereabouts of a child lost in this way
have been successful adolescents who
have not fully matured past puberty are
although more detailed manifestations
have been encountered within the area no
attempts to communicate with the
entities within scp-896 however as
confrontation of the phenomenon is not
required to contain it no tools
containing have been allocated to
scp-896
travel through the area is also hindered
by a spatial anomaly that makes land
navigation difficult compasses and GPS
navigation systems will give false
directions and trails through the under
bush will change course although there
are occasional sounds of wildlife within
the affected area no wild animals or
tracks have been observed within the
range of scp-896 although they will not
attempt to make physical contact
experiment 899 one conducted March 23rd
to May 15 2009 SCP 573 was transferred
to scp-896 the childlike manifestations
SCP 573 is successful in driving away
the manifestations
although the spatial anomaly that
complicates land travel within the area
remained due to the harmful effects of
prolonged exposure SCP 573 was returned
to containment at the conclusion of the
experiment scp-575 as they can
effectively be used to cancel each other
out there are no children or animals to
be exposed to SCP 573 inside this place
please reconsider and return 573 to my
care agent
incident report 899 25 June 10th 2009 a
new manifestation has been encountered
NSEP 899 the entity took the appearance
of an adolescent male covered in bloody
wounds rather than the normal
interaction it immediately attacked
doctor resulting in severe lacerations
and distinct bite marks on the arm neck
and upper thigh dr. Gupta is undergoing
treatment and quarantine incident report
899 26 on June 13th 2009 doctor is
released from quarantine with no
permanent damage beyond Scarn doctor
passed a psychiatric examination with
expected results and has been able to
give detailed recollections from his
youth despite contact with SCP 8 19 9
the new manifestation has been
classified 899 - one incident report 899
27 June 20th 2009 scp-896
have been observed in direct conflict
with other manifestations of SCP EA 99
SCP a 99 - one has also attacked the
cabin on the northern border and started
a fire which resulted in the death of a
gem
[Music]
although SCP 8 1991 can be deterred in
the same manner as a CP 8 99 the new
manifestations display a significant
increase in aggression would attempt to
kill research suggests that the change
in s EP 899 s phenomena is related to
exposure to SCP 573 no further cross SCP
experimentation with a CPA 99 is allowed
at this time 405 order okay
I'm glad I only have to teach you guys
about this one anyway that about does it
for today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed
good bye I would like to give a special
thank you to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim
Mookie slump God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick tie verbal OD 10
CH cheese whip I'm Depp's McGee thank
you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]